this is ingram angle from washington
tonight
dr oz is here with his first trip to the
angle since his run in pennsylvania you
do not want to miss it
but first
high hopes
well
low hopes that's the focus of tonight's
angle
now the democrats are getting desperate
they're running out of time
and they need you scared
these extreme weather events we are
experiencing they will impact the access
that we have to fossil fuels manage the
impact of climate change becoming more
extreme
more extreme weather we don't know what
the next shock is going to be a pandemic
a war a climate-related extreme weather
event which is happening more and more
frequently every passing year
now now he's a weather expert because he
handled the transportation thing so well
all right well here's the rule of thumb
if it's super hot out
it's climate change
and if it's super cold in the winter
it's climate change so whatever change
is happening it means you have to run
out and get an electric car
all right yeah for all their
fear-mongering the globalists are
worried that their dream of a
carbon-neutral world is fading away
because in just the past week a giant
climate spending bill that went down in
flames on capitol hill
and then germany's going back to coal it
turns out whoops and of course americans
are seething about gas prices
going up going up but uh
people paycheck ain't going up did
definitely cancel a long trip i was
thinking of making the season because of
the gas prices i can't afford gas
sometimes so you eat or buy gas
that's the way it goes now and it
shouldn't be like that in america
democrats are blaming republicans or
blaming mansion drivers who won't ditch
their gas guzzlers and of course
vladimir putin
they know their climate window is
closing
so they send up their drone
no one country can solve this problem by
itself
we all have to be able to reduce the
emissions we have to accelerate the
transition we're behind
we're not yet
fulfilling the promises that we made in
glasgow
so we have our work cut out for us
first let me translate this when john
heinz kerry talks about accelerating the
transition what he means is a transition
from when you had extra money in your
pocket to a time where you have none
from american prosperity to american
poverty
and the white house believes that you
should be happy to make this sacrifice
what do you say to those families who
say listen we can't afford to pay 485 a
gallon for months if not years about the
future of the liberal world order and we
have to stand firm
liberal world order you notice how they
never define what that actually means
and
did biden ever campaign on that concept
of the liberal world order as far as i
can tell the liberal world order stands
for i don't know what abortion
anti-americanism and eliminating our
energy independence to help other more
worthy countries
but just a few years ago
2018 2019 we had peace
we had no inflation no new wars we had
no inflation and even blue collar wages
were beginning to rise
of course that made the left absolutely
miserable
because democrats were happiest when you
were locked in your homes
waiting for the next fouchy press
conference
terrified of a virus with about a
99.97 survivability rate for people
under the age of 70
they loved it when your expectations
were low they called it the new normal
there was more alcohol and drug use more
students were falling behind zooming in
more mental illness
but the climate nuts they were thrilled
because they hoped that you were being
conditioned to be satisfied
with having less
with traveling less with making less
money because
we were keeping each other safe and the
planet cleaner
look outside look at the sky is it
clearer is the air cleaner
while fewer cars on the roads and planes
in our skies have helped the planet
breathe image on the left is what los
angeles skyline usually looks like where
you've got that smog there on the right
this was taken just about a week ago
much clearer skies and cleaner skies
because you don't have quite as much
pollution
they love no productivity the sky is
cleaner
and today the democrats and their global
allies they're back at it
this economic downturn you have to
understand this is not an accident
this impending recession isn't a
surprise
this is the biden agenda working as it
should
now if it weren't it weren't really
planned well bozos like janet yellen
would have been fired long ago whole
economic team would have been fired
but biden thinks they're all doing a
bang-up job
so we may not have formal lockdowns in
place
but americans are staying put because of
high gas prices 65 percent are spending
less on going out 61 percent are driving
less to do errands
half are traveling less and four in 10
are using savings to pay for day-to-day
expenses
same number by the way or spending less
on groceries
well i have to tell you that makes the
super rich who are driving this insane
climate lie ecstatic
and the globalists at the white house
and congress at the world economic forum
they've decided that to maintain their
own power and their own money and to
save the planet yeah they probably want
to do that too they must lower the
standard of living for the average
american
and by the way same is happening
elsewhere this is why the dutch are
wiping out their farmers this is why
europe doesn't have a smart energy
policy today
by the way their sustainability agenda
includes some key elements that they
have to force on western nations but
especially here in america
it requires taking agricultural land out
of production
reducing automobile traffic attacking
the fossil fuel industry keeping fuel
costs high reducing u.s manufacturing
and keeping the climate change
propaganda in schools corporate america
cartoons all of it and when the white
house by the way is pressed
on how long the pain will go on for
americans i want you to listen closely
this is a step that we're taking to
inflict further pain on putin
but there will be cost as well here in
the united states how long is it fair to
expect american drivers and drivers
around the world to pay that premium for
this war as long as it takes so russia
cannot in fact
defeat ukraine
as long as it takes
now democrats really thought that they
could convince you to voluntarily accept
a lower standard of living for your
families your kids your grandkids
and indeed many democrats they're
already on board with that agenda
remember liberals in the media and on
the hill
they're not turning on biden now because
they disagree with his policies they're
just turning on biden because he's such
a lame messenger more on that by the way
later on in the show
but the greeniacs ran into a new
phenomenon that they hadn't prepared for
they hadn't anticipated
i'm talking about new immigrants who
came here for a better life and they're
not willing to accept a lower standard
of living for a stupid climate fantasy
they would have stayed in their home
country
and it turns out and middle class
americans still want they want to live
in the suburbs they want to have two
cars they want to have good schools that
aren't propagandizing 24 7.
and these same people they're not
slavishly pouring over the academics who
are speaking out in the new york times
like economist herman daly who now is
urging america to rethink its obsession
with economic growth i read this over
the weekend and unbelievable he says
it's a false assumption to say that
growth is increasing the standard of
living in the present world because we
measure growth as in growth with gdp if
it goes up does that mean we're
increasing standard of living
we've said that it does but we've left
out all the costs of increasing gdp we
really don't know that the standard is
going up if you subtract the deaths and
the injuries caused my auto accidents
chemical pollution wildfires and many of
the other costs induced by excessive
growth it's not clear at all oh my god
they really are desperate trying to
totally upend the american dream now
think about where america would be today
if we
took hermann's attitude at the most
pivotal times in our history i don't
know our world war ii assembly lines you
know producing all those weapons with
all american-made steel and all the iron
we had to win the war the industrial
revolution guess we wouldn't have done
any of that think of the air pollution
that caused i guess we should have
stayed with horses
we'll never lose sight of the fact that
the green agenda is being pushed hardest
by those whose lives will be affected
least by the radical restructuring of
our economy
you believe this is the toughest
challenge humanity has ever faced
absolutely the
amount of change uh
new ideas it's way greater than the
pandemic and it needs a level of
cooperation
that would be unprecedented climate
change will kill five times as many
people per year
as the peak of the pandemic
by the end of the century and it will be
accelerating and without a a simple
tool
to stop that right away
keep your eye on him we are
and as we've been telling you for months
now the left and its enablers have given
up on americans
because in their minds
we deserve to be punished for the
country's wicked racist greedy history
but there is good news
you don't have to take this from the
climate control freaks because if you
beat them in november and again in 24
and you choose smart and courageous
america first conservatives
well our government's gonna have to stop
answering to the international
bureaucrats and people like bill gates
and george soros
they're gonna have to start answering
once again to we the people and that's
the angle hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else